[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 j'espère que
vous allez bien nous sommes le mercredi
18 janvier voici le programme top départ
pour les inscriptions sur la plateforme
parcoursup les lycéens ont jusqu'au 9
mars pour formuler leurs 10 vœux
d'orientation parmi 21 000 formations
alors comment s'y retrouver quelles sont
les choses à savoir avant de choisir sa
voix nous en parlerons avec nos invités
le magazine l'Étudiant l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
l'école d'ingénieurs eteo une nouvelle
entreprise d'envergure international va
s'implanter sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans la
commune de Guyancourt plus précisément
il s'agit de JST Group leader mondial
dans le domaine de la connectique dédiée
notamment à l'automobile l'objectif
construire leur Européen de Recherche et
Développement au total le bâtiment
devrait accueillir une centaine de
collaborateurs et comme chaque mercredi
nous parlerons de cinéma dans votre 7 8
quelles sont les films à ne pas manquer
cette semaine Babylone la guerre des
Lulu la le clan nous ferons le point
avec notre journaliste Ludivine canard
au programme également le coup de cœur
d'un professionnel du 7e art pour vous
replonger dans des classiques et avec
moi en plateau de dirigeants de startup
qui viennent de rejoindre le ski cube
alors le ski cube c'est en incubateur de
start-up il est basé à Guyancourt il a
pour but d'accompagner les entrepreneurs
dans leur dans leur début dans leur
stratégie cinq nouvelles entreprises
viennent d'être accueillies en ce début
d'année dont Médoc donc vous êtes le
dirigeant Vincent Miro bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde et chaque appel dont vous êtes
la dirigeante Awa Fofana bonsoir bonsoir
alors en un mot Vincent Miro quel est le
qu'est-ce que mes dope c'est une société
qui développe un logiciel qui optimise
l'utilisation du bloc opératoire donc
des hôpitaux des cliniques et qui veut
simplifier le travail des équipes
médicales soignante autour des processus
du bloc opératoire pareil même question
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que checkpad un
check tape c'est le copilote financier
du salarié qui va l'aider à mieux
comprendre sa rémunération de son entrée
dans l'entreprise jusqu'à sa sortie et
donc on en parlera en détail dans
quelques instants mais juste avant
jetons un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel devait être dégagé
sur l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau
des températures couvrez-vous bien il
fera 0° à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et
Versailles et moins 1 degré à
Rambouillet mais les ressentis seront
d'environ moins 4 degrés dans
l'après-midi météo France prévoit
quelques rares averses dans le
nord-ouest du département à Versailles
et Rambouillet attendez-vous à de la
pluie avec un peu de neige au niveau des
températures il fera 3 à 4 degrés en
moyenne et demain nous fêterons la saint
Marius le point maintenant sur
l'actualité dans les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous réginera lej bonsoir
bonsoir on commence par la grève contre
la réforme des retraites qui aura lieu
demain vie demain la mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites s'annonce forte
Olivier Véran le porte-parole du
gouvernement a d'ailleurs annoncé ce
matin en conférence de presse qui
l'espère que cette expression populaire
ne se transformera pas en blocage des
perturbations majeures sont donc
attendues dans les transports dans les
Yvelines c'est un train sur trois qui
circulera pour les lignes A et U un
train sur 10 pour les lignes
cjln et E
Île-de-France mobilité appellent
d'ailleurs les Franciliens à privilégier
le télétravail et offre le covoiturage
pendant les jours de grève grâce à son
partenariat avec les plateformes Carros
classiques et blablacar et du côté des
enseignants le
snuippfsu premier syndicat du primaire
annonce que 70% des enseignants du
premier degré seront grévistes on a
d'ailleurs été demandé aux Yvelines
comment il compte s'organiser demain on
écoute les réactions au micro de Julien
Leroy et Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
parce que les enfants seront à la maison
et il faut que soit moi je travaille pas
soit madame reste à la maison pour que
vous soyez les enfants il faut y aller
si on peut y aller justement c'est le
problème c'est si on peut pas aller à
Paris par les transports comment on va
la grève nous on avait partielle toute
la toute la journée demain et il a été
décalé à vendredi à cause des grèves
c'est pénible
surtout quand c'est des grèves générales
je suis à la retraite donc je n'ai pas
ce problème là voilà je devais aller à
Paris je n'irai pas enfin bon je suis
sûr que j'ai le choix mais quand on a
pas le choix on va s'arrêter une journée
avoir des grèves à répétition les jeudis
c'est pas une part en quoi c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils nous le font et
pour les gens qui doivent aller au
travail ou pour les étudiants bah c'est
pas très cool quand même et certaines
raffineries feront également grève
contre la réforme des retraites trois
préavis de grève ont été déposés par la
CGT certaines stations en Île-de-France
sont déjà du mal à s'approvisionner
alors faut-il craindre une nouvelle
pénurie de carburant Patrick Jacques de
dismut et Julien Leroy sont aussi allés
demander aux Yvelines s'ils avaient
cette crainte aujourd'hui je fais mon
plein pour anticiper les grèves
j'ai pas envie d'être en panne
effectivement j'ai commencé à paniquer
donc je me suis dit d'habitude je prends
pour un certain somme là je vais prendre
un petit peu plus mais bon on le vit au
jour le jour je veux dire moi j'ai pas
j'ai pas réellement de craintes par
rapport à ça j'essaie de faire un plan
de restituer toujours sur un plat en cas
où il y a vraiment opinion pour tenir
les premières 15 jours en toute
honnêteté j'ai déjà à la maison j'ai
déjà 20 litres je suis en moto je me
rassure si ça continue
va falloir s'adapter et essayer de faire
avec puis on va subir quoi vous êtes
inquiet autour du plateau sur une
nouvelle potentielle pénurie de
carburant est-ce que ça vous inquiète
Régine Vincent mirofana
non
et optimiste donc après évidemment
j'espère que le blocage ne sont pas ne
seront pas trop durs la lumière ne le
dira
beaucoup de stations services qui
étaient en pénurie à côté de chez moi
donc c'est pas toujours rassurant alors
concernant cette situation en tout cas
la ministre de la transition écologique
Agnès rue naché a souhaité rassurer sur
l'état des stocks en France elle demande
notamment aux Français de ne pas se ruer
dans les stations services durant les
prochains jours car je cite on n'est pas
du tout dans la situation de l'automne
dernier on poursuit ces informations du
jour Régine avec des perquisitions
menées hier soir notamment au conseil
départemental oui vous l'avez dit des
perquisitions ont été menées au conseil
départemental des Yvelines à la mairie
de Mantes-la-Jolie ainsi qu'au domicile
de plusieurs personnes dont celui du
président du conseil départemental
pierre Bédié c'est perquisitions font
suite à une enquête ouverte en juin
dernier pour atteinte à la probité après
que l'association de lutte contre la
corruption anticorps 78 a fait parteni a
fait parvenir pardon à la justice un
dossier concernant une subvention versée
par le département des Yvelines pour la
construction d'une maison médicale à
Mantes-la-Jolie ce projet d'un peu plus
d'un million d'euros serait selon
l'association anticorps porté par une
société privée créée en un temps record
par le beau-frère du président du
conseil départemental et un entrepreneur
local qu'il connaissait cette subvention
a été votée à l'unanimité par le Conseil
départemental des Yvelines et également
voter par le conseil municipal de
Mantes-la-Jolie c'est le pôle régional
financier de Nanterre qui est chargé
dans l'enquête et à la suite de ses
perquisitions le président du conseil
départemental Pierre Bédier a adressé un
message aux élus du département mais
sache que nous sommes procurés et dans
lequel Pierre Bédié écrit ceci mes chers
collègues sans doute l'aurez-vous
compris mon domicile puis le Conseil
départemental ont été perquisitionnés
dans le cadre de l'affaire dite de la
maison médicale de Mantes-la-Jolie à la
lecture des documents saisis qu'il
aurait suffi de nous réclamer les
enquêteurs constateront très vite qu'il
y a des élus et des fonctionnaires qui
agissent pour le bien public en
respectant toutes les procédures je suis
totalement serein et ma seule
contrariété est pour le stress
occasionné aux collaborateurs par cette
opération spectaculaire on poursuit par
une information une triste nouvelle à
Rambouillet ce matin un incendie mortel
a été déclaré où vit les pompiers du
SDIS 78 sont intervenus ce matin aux
alentours de 7h30 pour un instant pour
un incident survenu dans un immeuble
trois corps calcinés ont été retrouvés
celui d'une femme d'origine bulgare et
celui de ses deux enfants âgés de 8 et
18 ans ces derniers occupaient le
logement illégalement le tribunal de
proximité de Rambouillet saisi par le
titulaire du bail à ordonné le 17
janvier 2023 l'expulsion de l'occupante
la police judiciaire de Versailles est
saisie de l'enquête la piste du meurtre
semble privilégié alors je le disais à
l'instant dans les titres une nouvelle
entreprise internationale va venir
s'installer sur le territoire de 50 ans
en Yvelines oui c'est le groupe japonais
JST déjà présent sur le territoire
depuis 2006 le groupe a signé avec
l'agglomération ce matin l'acquisition
d'un terrain agui en cours pour
construire son futur Centre Européen de
Recherche et Développement leader
mondial dans le domaine de la
connectique électronique ce groupe
réalisent deux milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires dont 33 % dans le
secteur automobile alors la construction
du bâtiment que vous pouvez voir à
l'image se fera à proximité du campus
des métiers de l'automobile et du
Technocentre Renault d'ailleurs je tiens
à préciser que ces images dates du mois
de septembre et que les plans sont en
évolution les travaux doivent commencer
au mois de mars et le site devrait être
inauguré à la fin du premier semestre
2024 le centre accueillera près de sans
collaborateurs on écoute le directeur
général de GST France Patrice Blondel
sur la stratégie du groupe les
stratégique parce qu'il est proche de
nos clients savoir c'était lundi Renault
Valeo qui sont des clients
à fort potentiel pour pour JST et on
développe un partenariat depuis plus de
20 ans avec et donc être proche du
client c'est vraiment dans l'axe
de la manière d'agir de la culture
japonaise au moins de l'entreprise c'est
customer Nice c'est le besoin du client
et voilà le client a besoin d'avoir ses
fournisseurs près de lui si on s'arrête
sur l'industrie automobile vous vous
retrouvez les connecteurs GST dans le
lighting dans tout ce qui est éclairage
dans le tableau de bord dans les
systèmes de sécurité avec les airbags on
est très content d'avoir un acteur aussi
puissant en plus c'est quand même sur
des secteurs extrêmement stratégiques
d'ailleurs leur premier client sont des
clients qui sont à 50 ans en Yvelines
notamment sur l'autonomie ou que ce soit
Validéo que ce soit
tout secteur automobile et on termine
par l'image du jour Régine c'est l'Urban
loop le nouveau moyen de transport
innovant à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
des petites capsules électriques
automatisées seront mises en service
d'ici le mois de mai 2024 à l'occasion
des Jeux Olympiques ces véhicules
pourront transporter deux personnes à
une allure d'environ 50 km/h et le
circuit d'un kilomètre ira du grand
parking de la base de loisirs au Relais
Des au Relais Des canardières lieu
d'hébergement de l'île de loisirs à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines merci beaucoup
Régine rallès et si vous aussi comme
d'habitude vous voyez une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news
on en parlait en début d'émission les
inscriptions débutent aujourd'hui sur la
plateforme parcoursup les lycéens
doivent formuler leurs vœux
d'orientation d'ici le mois de mars avec
nous pour en parler ruddych assoko
bonsoir
est-ce que vous m'entendez
vous êtes alors vous êtes commercial
plurimédia pour le magazine l'Étudiant
avec nous également Séverine delaverne
bonsoir alors vous êtes la directrice de
l'école d'ingénieur aiséo basé à
Vélizy-Villacoublay nous sommes aussi à
avec Marie Emma boursier bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes aussi connectés à
distance avec nous vous êtes
vice-présidente de la Commission
Formation et vie universitaire pour
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors première
question plutôt pour ruddish à Soko sur
parcoursup un nouveau moteur de
recherche plus intuitif a été mis en
place cette année pour pour faciliter
l'information et que ce soit plus clair
pour les étudiants est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer comment ça
fonctionne
c'est à moi que vous allez poser la
question
alors pour parcoursup pour le coup donc
la phase d'inscription commence
aujourd'hui donc les étudiants vont
pouvoir faire 10 choix d'abord 10 choix
de formation initiale et ensuite et
aussi du choix de formation d'alternance
donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas il n'y
a pas de hiérarchisation réellement de
leur choix c'est d'avoir un peu ils
doivent choisir un peu ce qui leur
plaisent qu'ils veulent et donc pour les
aider on a le salon qui aura lieu ce
week-end au Vélodrome pour les guider
dans dans leur choix d'orientation et
donc il y a eu plusieurs formations qui
ont été ajoutées c'est une nouveauté
cette année est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus quels sont quels
sont ces formations nouvelles sur la
plateforme alors pour le coup les
formations en elle-même nouvelle j'en ai
pas le nom mais il y a 20 000 formations
en tout sur parcoursup et pour tout et
chaque chaque formation est bien
documentée donc chaque
qui sont présents sur parcoursup
documente donc pour le coup
je pourrais pas vous donner le nom des
formations mais vous avez un gros panel
de formation sur le sur le parcoursup
alors comment est-ce que ça fonctionne
on rentre une formation mais il me
semble que sur un vœu on peut le
catégoriser le déplier en plusieurs vœux
alors je vous avoue que je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas toutes ces informations
clairement par parcours et la procédure
mais par exemple sur le salon de 50 ans
Yvelines ce week-end on a une formation
qui sera présentée par l'académie de
Versailles qui explique la procédure en
détail et vous pourrez avoir du coup ces
informations sur salon ce week-end
Séverine delave peut-être que vous avez
juste préciser qu'effectivement il y a
10 vœux et il y a 20 sous vœux et en
fonction de la catégorie des vœux il y a
des universités ou des écoles qui sont
regroupées notamment les écoles
d'ingénieurs sont regroupées et donc
souvent le sous vœu correspond à un
souveux et pas plusieurs sous vœux voilà
donc c'est un petit peu technique mais
il y a au moins 10 vœux et 20 sous vœux
à sélectionner en fait voilà et donc
vous le disiez à l'instant redish à Soko
il va y avoir le Salon de l'Étudiant ce
sera ce samedi 21 janvier qu'est-ce
comment est-ce qu'on peut se préparer
pour pour aller à ce salon est-ce qu'il
y a des choses à préparer en amont
alors
première chose le salon est totalement
gratuit donc on a une plateforme hybride
donc une plateforme en ligne le salon en
ligne il faut passer par cette
plateforme là pour s'inscrire et donc
cette année nous avons mis en place en
fait cette plateforme afin d'aider les
visiteurs à préparer leur donc leur
parcours et donc leur choix
d'orientation donc quand ils arrivent
sur la plateforme ils ont la liste des
exposants la liste de nos conférences et
donc qui peuvent donc déjà contacté
certains des exposants et les ajouter à
leur parcours de visite pour que en
arrivant sur le salon à aller les
rencontrer directement et avoir toutes
les informations en fait en amont et
donc la plateforme elle est ouverte
qu'un jour avant elle était déjà ouverte
depuis début janvier et elle fermera à
trois jours après le salon donc le 24 le
24 janvier
avec les exposants
Marie Emma boursier l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
sera présente au salon de l'étudiant
le seul acteur public universitaire de
secteur de ce territoire donc nous
sommes évidemment présents avec une
offre de formation très large puisque
nous sommes une université
pluridisciplinaire avec des composantes
qui ont des sciences dures
mais sociales management etc donc on est
traditionnellement présent sur
surne vous serez présente au salon
pourquoi c'est important pour les écoles
les universités d'être présent au Salon
de l'Étudiant alors c'est d'abord
d'aller à la rencontre des potentiels
candidats et de les renseigner surtout
sur par rapport à leur parcours leur
choix de parcours voilà c'est important
pour eux d'avoir le bon niveau
d'information pour saisir justement dans
parcoursup
la formation qui leur correspond le
mieux parce que un jeune qui va sur une
formation qui ne connaît pas ou qui qui
lui plaît pas forcément réussira pas
forcément alors que il a un bon niveau
donc le choix de la formation et crucial
en fait il faut que vous les aidez à
choisir leur formation à les aiguiller
alors nous à le zéro on va effectivement
on a les salons les journées portes
ouvertes voilà on va à la rencontre on
va aussi dans les lycées pour leur
expliquer déjà ce qu'est le métier de
l'ingénieur parce que c'est un métier
qui est pas forcément bien connu enfin
on n'entend parler du métier d'ingénieur
mais pour un jeune ils comprennent pas
exactement ce que ça implique derrière
donc on leur explique déjà ce qu'est le
métier de l'ingénieur et ensuite en
fonction de leur appétence pour les
sciences par exemple on va pouvoir les
aiguiller sur un tel ou tel domaine ou
alors vers d'autres types de formation
donc le conseil qu'on fait nous au sein
de de Zéo enfin il est assez large en
fait c'est à dire que si on voit à part
venir à notre rencontre des jeunes qui
se cherchent etc on pourra aussi leur
donner des bons conseils pour aller vers
d'autres formations qui leur
correspondraient plus en fait c'est ça
qui est important c'est d'avoir un vrai
projet un vrai choix par rapport à une
formation et alors durant le Salon de
l'Étudiant il y aura aussi des
conférences redites à Soko c'est aussi
un moyen pour pour aider les étudiants à
trouver leur voie
oui en effet les conférences elles sont
faites pour ça c'est un peu l'objectif
aussi de ce salon c'est de pouvoir en
fait mettre toutes les informations à
disposition des étudiants et des
étudiants pour qu'ils puissent faire
leur bon choix donc comme je vous disais
juste avant on a l'académie de
Versailles qui fera une conférence sur
parcoursup
l'université qui freine conférence et de
même on a notre rédaction qui est aussi
enfin qui fait des conférences donc en
tout cas sur leurs interrogations liées
à parcoursup et
sur le panel de formation qui peuvent
avoir dans le dans la localité dans tout
ce qui est local
local à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ils
auront les informations sur le salon et
via les conférences et on l'a compris il
y aura une conférence sur parcoursup
pour expliquer comment fonctionne la
plateforme quels seront les autres
thèmes des conférences
alors on a donc l'université qui va un
peu parler de comment entrer à
l'université on a aussi des une forme
une conférence sur les formations
métiers de management commerce et de
gestion aussi une autre conférence sur
btsbut un peu comment choisir sa filière
après le bac et une conférence sur les
études scientifiques et technologiques
pour un peu balayer la totalité des
secteurs Marie Emma boursier du coup on
a compris il y aura une conférence sur
et comment entrer à l'université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quelles sont
quelles sont les changements quand on
entre à l'université est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus
sur cette conférence bien sûr alors
peut-être déjà une précision au fond on
reçoit des étudiants dans ce type de
salon comme dans nos journées portes
ouvertes qui se dérouleront le 4 février
prochain qui ont déjà quand même une
idée de leur orientation ne serait-ce
que par leur origine de filière du bac
et je crois que ce qu'on peut leur
apporter dans ce genre de rencontre
c'est de ou d'invalider ou précisément
des alerter sur les points faibles et
les points forts qu'auraient leur profil
et pour optimiser les chances d'avoir la
formation que j'ai choisie parce qu'il y
a un enjeu pour eux parce qu'il y a un
nombre de volumilité et puis surtout
après pour qu'il soit
leur profil soit en adéquation avec les
attendus que vous trouvez sur parcoursup
l'université des dizaines de licences
qu'elle propose indique pour chacune des
licences chacune des disciplines
l'ensemble des attendus d'hyper requis
qui permettent déjà à l'étudiant de se
situer parfois comme endroit la faculté
de droit de Versailles il y a même
proposant des tests de positionnement
c'est-à-dire c'est un test absolument
fait par l'étudiant sur la base du
volontariat leur aide avoir une petite
idée ça de l'adéquation de son profil
avec les études qu'il souhaite embrasser
et je crois que l'objet de la conférence
de samedi au Salon de l'Étudiant c'est
de présenter
la spécificité de l'université à
l'université sa spécificité c'est
qu'elle assure avec les enseignants
chercheurs une double mission une
mission d'enseignement mais sur
l'enseignement qui est appuyée sur sa
mission fondamentale sa seconde mission
fondamentale qui est une mission de
recherche et c'est tout ce que l'on peut
apporter à nos étudiants de nourrir les
enseignements qui leur sont délivrés par
la recherche alors avec un contexte un
contexte très très différent de ce
qu'ils ont connu au lycée et ça fait
partie des questions qu'on a très très
couramment lorsqu'on se déplace dans les
lycées et on est au contact des
bacheliers plutôt bacheliers dans ces
salons beaucoup d'interrogations sur les
modalités des cours entre les cours
magistraux les travaux dirigés la vie
étudiante donc c'est un changement mais
qui est aussi une étape évidemment dans
la vie étudiante je crois que le
présupposé la réussite étant un choix en
adéquation avec des capacités et le
souhait évidemment de les et alors
est-ce que et alors est-ce que la crise
sanitaire a eu un impact dans le choix
d'orientation des étudiants est-ce que
vous avez remarqué une différence entre
avant et après covid
dans le choix d'orientation des
étudiants non par rapport au chiffre
parcoursup c'est-à-dire on demande que
nous avons qui dépend en fait des
filières il y a des filières notoirement
sous tension et puis d'autres dans
lesquels il y a un petit peu loin de un
petit peu moins de pression
il y a la crise du covid on a vu les
résultats en revanche sur l'implication
et les difficultés des étudiants qui qui
ont commencé leurs études et de rentrer
dans le enseignement supérieur l'année
du covid ça a été très délétère pour eux
puisque il y avait la difficulté de
l'approche à distance pour laquelle nous
étions voilà dans une composition assez
difficile et puis l'absence de vie
étudiante parce que tout le l'agrément
c'est aussi ça il y a les contraintes de
l'autonomie et puis son agrément aussi
autour d'une vie de campus qui à
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines par les Saclay
et particulièrement développé avec via
associative étudiante très riche et
beaucoup plus dans lesquels nous
étudiants peuvent aussi
s'épanouir Séverine delaverne je vous
vois au chier de la tête c'est aussi
quelque chose que vous avez remarqué
avec le covid effectivement les élèves
sont enfin en tous les cas voilà ceux
qui sont passés par cette crise là sont
moins bien préparés à l'enseignement
supérieur et effectivement tout ce qui
touche la construction même de
l'individu l'autonomie et les les
savoirs aussi enfin les connaissances
techniques qui peuvent avoir
ne sont pas forcément très consolidés
donc ça veut dire que voilà nous en tant
que l'école on met en place aussi un
accompagnement personnalisé pour pouvoir
aider ces élèves là qui par moments sont
un peu en difficulté voilà pour qu'ils
puissent réussir en fait sur leur
parcours et bien merci beaucoup Ruddy
asoko et Marie Emma boursier d'avoir
accepté notre invitation c'est vrai
delaverne vous restez avec nous puisque
c'est un nouveau rendez-vous qu'on va
vous proposer chaque mercredi nous
partirons à la découverte d'une école
dans les Yvelines on commence avec
ezeo Régine rallès que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus alors comme vous
l'avez dit et Zéo est une école
d'ingénieur elle est spécialisée dans la
transformation numérique c'est à dire
qu'elle s'intéresse globalement à toutes
les mutations numériques digitales et
technologiques de la société le diplôme
obtenu peut être un Bachelor un master
ou un doctoration souhaite aller plus
loin et en sortie d'école les métiers
sont variés on peut devenir architecte
système consultant chef de projet
ingénieur en recherche et développement
et ce dans plusieurs secteurs tels que
l'automobile l'aéronautique l'énergie ou
la banque par exemple et un point qui me
semble effectivement important de mettre
en avant c'est son ouverture à
l'international puisque les étudiants
peuvent effectuer des stages des
échanges à l'étranger mais peuvent
également préparer des doubles diplômes
internationaux avec des universités
partenaires on peut d'ailleurs citer par
exemple l'Illinois instituts of
Technology de Chicago aux États-Unis ou
bien l'université de Belgrano à Buenos
Aires en Argentine ou encore
l'Université de Sherbrooke au Canada les
héros en quelques chiffres ces trois
campus en France à Vélizy-Villacoublay
Angers et Dijon 1500 étudiants 50
grandes entreprises partenaires et 6800
diplômés et enfin 66 années d'expérience
puisque l'école a été fondée en 1956 et
j'ajoute à cela que depuis 2020 eteo
fait partie des 104 écoles d'ingénieurs
françaises accrédité CTI Commission des
Titres d'Ingénieurs alors madame de
Laverne ma première question est la
suivante comment intégrer cette école
alors pour intégrer l'école il y a
plusieurs parcours en fonction de son
profil et de son bac c'est-à-dire qu'on
a bac maintenant une science de sciences
avec la réforme du bac voilà par exemple
et on a aussi les bacs STI2D donc de
toute façon pour pouvoir intégrer le Zéo
il faut aller on passe par un concours
qui s'appelle le concours puissance
alpha où en fait on va retrouver un
regroupement d'écoles ingénieurs on
partage le même concours donc il faut
aller sur parcoursup dans les fameux
vœux aller chercher le concours
puissance alpha et ensuite vous allez
sélectionner les écoles et les parcours
que vous souhaitez intégrer donc il peut
y avoir des classes préparatoires nous
on a une classe préparatoire intégrée
internationale et une avec un parcours
innovation technologique en fait qui
existent et on a également une
possibilité de rentrer chez nous avec
sur un Bachelor donc avec trois
composantes sur ce Bachelor en fonction
du campus la coloration du Bachelor en
fait elle est liée aussi à l'expertise
que l'on a sur le campus mais aussi à
l'environnement en termes d'entreprise
aux alentours c'est à dire qu'on adapte
nos Bachelor en fonction du besoin
d'experts sur le territoire voilà et nos
Bachelor enfin toutes nos formations
sont construites en fonction du besoin
exprimé par les industriels de manière à
coller au plus proche de du besoin
territorial voilà donc pour postuler il
faut choisir voilà parcoursup conco
puissance alpha allez sélectionner la
formation qui correspond à son parcours
à son à son attaques aussi type de bac
ensuite soit il y a un pour les bacs de
sciences et pas qu'une science il peut y
avoir des épreuves écrites voilà pour
les st2d il y a que un dossier et un
entretien donc voilà il y a souvent il y
a de toute façon un dossier à constituer
plus des épreuves écrites et sur notre
campus on prépare aussi à ces épreuves
écrites on a deux demi-journées de
préparation à ce concours qui sont
complètement gratuites il faut juste
s'inscrire pour l'objectif c'est de les
préparer au mieux à ce concours en fait
et combien d'étudiants rentrent chaque
année à l'école eteo alors sur chacun de
nos campus donc sur Angers et Paris sur
le cycle préparatoire intégré on a à peu
près une cinquantaine de places voilà
donc il y a de la place pour pouvoir
rentrer à leuzeo il faut surtout
postuler parce qu'en fait souvent les
jeunes ont peur de postuler voilà il
faut pas s'interdire de pouvoir postuler
il y a tout à fait c'est tout à fait
possible d'intégrer le Zéo est-ce que
vous faites aussi de l'apprentissage
alors oui on fait de l'apprentissage on
a ouvert cette année en septembre
2022 donc notre première formation en
apprentissage sur le campus de Vélizy
Villacoublay c'est le même diplôme
d'ingénieur qui est délivré la formation
de l'apprentissage existe aussi depuis
longtemps sur notre campus d'Angers donc
nous on l'a ouvert simplement cette
année on a cette année
28 élèves en fait qui sont en contrat
d'apprentissage avec les entreprises du
territoire voilà et on valide à la fois
l'entreprise les sujets qui sont confiés
à l'apprenti et on le suit tout au cours
de fin tout au long de sa scolarité
voilà pendant les trois ans donc là on
démarre et on ouvre une classe
supplémentaire à l'entrée donc on aura
48 places à la rentrée prochaine est-ce
que ça ça peut vous intéresser des
élèves qui sortent de cette école
Vincent Miro et Awa Fofana
je vous prends un peu dépourvu
quel type d'élèves de formation
on a des équipes et justement comme on
est en développement on va recruter des
des ingénieurs qui interviennent sur sur
des technologies sur le numérique et en
accompagnement de nos clients donc on
est tout à fait tout à fait dans la
cible de du type de de personnes qu'on
va qu'on va rechercher
la tête
l'idée c'est que on est devant
entrepreneur on a des idées des rêves
mais il nous faut des équipes pour les
rendre en faire une réalité donc
forcément oui voir des jeunes qui ont
des compétences ça va forcément nous
intéresser Régine vous aviez une autre
question pour
ezeo oui effectivement mais c'est vrai
aussi que les étudiants aspirent à une
vie étudiante assez mouvementée est-ce
que justement il y a une vie associative
qui est importante sur les campus alors
oui oui tout à fait voilà non seulement
elle est déjà très riche mais en plus
ils peuvent contribuer à créer leur
propre club par exemple j'encourage
vraiment vivement la création des clubs
au niveau des étudiants je les
accompagne ses créations et aujourd'hui
on doit pas être loin d'une quinzaine de
clubs et justement sur le premier
semestre on a eu la création de quatre
clubs
supplémentaires avec un club sur
l'éloquence par exemple un club finance
un club cuisine par exemple donc on bien
sûr on a aussi des clubs sports plus
classiques voilà mais non ça fonctionne
très très bien on a une vie associative
assez riche et surtout ça fait partie
pour nous de la formation c'est à dire
qu'en fait on encourage nos élèves à
innover dans la création des clubs et à
gérer aussi le club le fonctionnement
les budgets l'organisation d'événements
ça fait partie intégrante aussi de la
formation donc pour nous c'est un point
indispensable à l'acquisition des
compétences nécessaires au métier de
l'ingénieur en fait et à la sortie de la
dernière question Régine rage parce
qu'on est un peu prise par le temps mais
allez-y une question très importante
quels sont les secteurs les plus prisés
à la sortie de l'école alors en ce
moment c'est la cybersécurité
l'intelligence artificielle tout ce qui
tourne autour de la donnée et tout ce
qui d'affaires aujourd'hui on est
vraiment basé sur les métiers des
nouvelles technologies voilà dans les
domaines que je viens de citer mais
aussi le transport est véhicule
intelligent on a vu qu'il y avait
effectivement une grosse entreprise qui
s'est installée dans le domaine de
l'automobile on est complètement en
phase avec les besoins du territoire et
aujourd'hui voilà on n'a pas de
problématique d'embauche de nos
ingénieurs on a plus d'offres que de
jeunes à placer en fait donc aujourd'hui
l'emploi est garanti si on choisit de
faire une formation d'ingénieur d'autant
plus dans nos domaines des nouvelles
technologies on est c'est la garantie
d'avoir un emploi avant même d'être
diplômé voilà alors on va parler d'un
outil à présent Séverine de Laverne ça
pourrait peut-être vous intéresser ça
s'appelle ma prépa numérique s'est
développée par pop school un centre de
formation au métier du numérique et pour
en parler nous sommes avec Baptiste
Dufour bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes le responsable
marketing et communication de popschool
situé à Élancourt alors ma numérique
c'est une plateforme qui permet d'aider
les personnes dans leur orientation
professionnelle par rapport au métier du
numérique comment ça fonctionne cet
outil concrètement
alors très simple les personnes qui sont
intéressées par la filière du numérique
qui ne savent pas quel domaine parce
qu'il y a tellement de domaines dans le
numérique aller on leur propose en fait
un parcours de 30 heures qui se
décompose en plusieurs étapes la
première étape les personnes vont se
connecter à la plateforme ils vont avoir
un test d'orientation qui va leur
permettre en fait d'avoir accès soit un
domaine un parcours dans la
cybersécurité soit dans la communication
digitale soit dans le design web ou bien
soit dans la programmation à partir du
moment ils ont accès en fait à
7h de parcours et à la fin il valide un
open badge qui vient à tester en fait
leur motivation à la fin notre objectif
est simple c'est permettre à la personne
de en fait se tester concrètement grâce
à des vidéos avec un formateur grâce à
la plateforme
e-learning pour pouvoir se dire bon bah
ok j'ai suivi cette heure en
cybersécurité à la fin la cybersécurité
ça me plaît c'est top du coup j'ai la
possibilité de m'orient vers des écoles
qui proposent des domaines dans la
cybersécurité comme on vient juste comme
vous venez juste d'en parler ou bien la
cybersécurité c'est absolument pas fait
pour moi parce qu'en fait je suis plus
créatif et je m'orientais davantage vers
des parcours
qui me correspondent davantage
Séverine de Laverne
vous je pense que ça peut être très
utile parce qu'en fait on parle à un
jeune qui a le bac de cybersécurité ce
qui l'en connaît c'est pas grand chose
en fait c'est ce qu'il a vu dans des
films ou le peu de documentation auquel
il a accès il y a une méconnaissance
quand même globalement des métiers donc
je pense que c'est un outil qui peut les
aider à construire le parfum le parcours
professionnel en fait en tous les cas le
choix et les orientes les orientations
que leur que leur formation pourrait
prendre pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de lancer cet outil là Baptiste
du four
alors comme vous l'avez dit d'après
Panin numérique c'est propulsé par un
organisme de formation qui s'adresse qui
a qu'à sept ans cette année et pendant 7
ans en fait quand on quand on s'adresse
nous essentiellement je préfère le dire
à des personnes en situation de
décrochage scolaire et aussi à des
personnes en reconversion
professionnelle et du coup les publics
qui arrivaient chez nous en fait en
entretien de motivation
sans fin s'orienter en fait faire un
parcours qualifiant de par exemple je
vais prendre un exemple mais de
développeur web et en fait suite à dans
le cadre de nos échanges on se rendait
compte qu'en fait le métier de
développeur web il était pas il était il
était un peu nébuleux pour et bon alors
développement on comprend très bien mais
par contre en effet si on prend le
domaine de la cybersécurité il y a
énormément de métiers derrière ça allait
ce constat et et là et du coup on s'est
dit que c'était quand même intéressant
pour mieux orienter les personnes de
leur permettre d'avoir accès
gratuitement en amont du coup de
l'orientation a du contenu très concret
sur sur et bien sûr sur sur leur future
métier sur le sur le métier sur le
quotidien
d'une personne qui exerce par exemple
demain dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité
80 000 emplois sont non pourvus dans les
dans le secteur du numérique dans les
métiers du numérique comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquez ce chiffre
comme on disait à l'instant c'est un
chiffre qui ressort souvent le 88000
emplois non pourvu ce chiffre c'est il
est il est comment il est mis à jour à
chaque année mais bon il est un peu
constant par par Pôle Emploi aujourd'hui
et bien on a eu une accélération des
besoins comment on disait par exemple en
cybersécurité je compte partage à 100%
le fait qu'aujourd'hui il y a une sorte
de demande dans les dans la cible
d'insécurité à l'arrivée comment
l'explosion de la data ça ça
fait exploser un certain nombre comment
de sa développer des nouveaux métiers
par exemple une situation sanitaire
qu'on a vécu donc qui est un peu loin
mais qui est quand même assez proche
avec l'évolution par exemple de tout ce
qui était e-commerce nous on l'a vu dans
nos formations ou d'un coup on a eu
énormément de de bois qui sont venus
chercher nos apprenants sur des
formations en Dave en programmation en
fait les besoins ils sont ils sont réels
la transformation numérique aujourd'hui
de la société c'est c'est notre
quotidien quoi du on se lève on a
forcément en contact avec avec le web
avec le numérique on se couche on a eu
je sais pas combien d'interactions
grâce à une Amérique quoi justement je
rebondis sur ce que sur ce que vous
venez de dire on vit avec le numérique
on se lève on se couche avec le
numérique est-ce que en quelque sorte ça
rend le secteur du numérique plus
attractif pour les jeunes aujourd'hui
il y a un vrai intérêt en effet
aujourd'hui pour pour le numérique en
tout cas moi je peux parler pour pour
pop school on voit en effet qu'il y a de
plus en plus de personnes qui qui
s'intéressent au domaine on a quand même
aussi
de plus en plus de personnes sur les
publics par exemple de reconversion
professionnelle qui ont exercé un métier
et qui s'intéresse samedi j'étais à
j'étais un salon en région parisienne
bon c'était un salon à destination des
des jeunes pour pour parcoursup mais les
parents derrière quand on se posait
quand même la question de faire une
reconversion dans le numérique alors
qu'ils sont ils ont comment ils sont
infirmiers ils ont des professions qui
ont rien à voir aujourd'hui il y a un
vrai réel et de plus en plus de monde et
attiré quoi par parce que il y a
vraiment des opportunités qui sont qui
sont à saisir donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant
et bien merci Baptiste Dufour d'avoir
été à visio en distance avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes le responsable
marketing et communication de l'école
pop school situé à Élancourt après avoir
parlé orientation et formation un point
maintenant sur l'économie et plus
particulièrement sur l'entrepreneuriat
c'est avec vous Nicolas dandry bonsoir
vous venez de nous rejoindre et on va
parler du ski cube qui a soufflé 6 ans
d'existence pour l'incubateur de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est situé
donc à Guyancourt et il a déjà
accompagné 60 startups vous savez à
travers des programmes à la fois
d'incubation mais aussi d'accélération
c'est destiné notamment à des startups
qui sont déjà existantes et qui se
développent et dans le dernier numéro
avec Patrick Jacques de dixmu nous
sommes allés au ski cube le dernier
numéro du Sky Eco le magazine économique
que vous pouvez retrouver sur sur le
site internet ou sur nos réseaux sociaux
et bien on est allé voir Jean-Luc mero
le directeur du ski qui tire le bilan et
bien de l'activité du
[Musique]
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on a ouvert ce
site il y avait quelque part une notion
un peu d'expérimentation puisque c'était
nouveau pour le territoire de
Saint-Quentin et on se rend compte que
après 5 6 années maintenant de
l'activité qu'il a toute son utilité et
qui qui s'est doté de riches
d'expérience au bénéfice des entreprises
du territoire alors le principe de
l'incubateur c'est d'accueillir des
startups pour les faire grandir les
lancer comment quel bilan vous faites en
termes de chiffres combien d'entreprises
vous avez accueillies alors des startups
vous avez raison puisque c'est quelque
part la vitrine du site avec notre
incubateur dont on parlera sans doute
mais beaucoup d'autres projets et de
d'action porter à destination des
entreprises en création d'entreprise
d'une manière générale mais également
avec les entreprises en activité
principalement autour des des ressources
humaines et l'accompagnement en termes
de RH voilà donc beaucoup beaucoup de
d'activités et l'incubateur pour
terminer sur sur ce sujet là
l'incubateur avec plus d'une soixantaine
de startups qui accueilli et accompagné
durant ses premières années d'activité
est-ce que il y a des histoires qui vous
ont marqué des succès story économiques
nés ici à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
dont on est particulièrement fiers vous
allez effectivement rencontrer
quelques-unes je pourrais en évoquer
d'autres comme l'Accord que
effectivement que vous avez déjà avec
lequel vous avez déjà eu l'occasion
d'échanger dans d'autres d'autres
contextes voilà des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui
tracent leur chemin mobilisent des fonds
arrivent à avoir une bonne relation avec
l'écosystème du territoire et si je ne
prends l'exemple que l'accord c'est pour
nous un exemple qu'on cite souvent parce
qu'il est eu un cheminement au-delà de
l'accompagnement qu'on a pu lui proposer
d'intégration dans l'écosystème puisqu'à
kermesse qui est une très belle PME du
territoire a pris une participation dans
dans cette entreprise est aujourd'hui un
acteur capital sans jeu de mots dans la
dynamique en tout cas dans le
développement de cette startup qu'on a
eu le plaisir d'accompagner pendant
quelques années
[Musique]
Vincent Miro de nouveau deux dirigeants
qui vont intégrer le ski cube de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on vient de
l'entendre l'accord c'est un exemple
pour le ski cube donc c'est une startup
qui a été incubé bon c'est des portiques
un concept de sûreté pour protéger les
grands événements c'est pas le même
activité que vous mais est-ce que ce
sera un rêve peut-être de collaborer
avec une PME une ti un grand groupe
peut-être avec votre startup à terme
quand on est quand on crée une société
comme ça on recherche évidemment le
des partenariats des des
on nous un réseau qui nous va nous
permettre évidemment de développer notre
activité donc avec cette société là en
particulier je ne sais pas je ne la
connais pas peut-être pas puisque bon
des portiques de sécurité c'est pas
forcément très en lien mais c'est vrai
que ça fait toujours plaisir de voir des
sociétés comme ça qui réussissent et
c'est proche de nous puisque voilà ils
sont passés
dans l'incubateur qu'on intègre
aujourd'hui donc voilà
on est au bon endroit
vous avez rejoint alors peut-être
rappeler votre projet votre concept
d'abord et puis pourquoi avoir rejoint
le ski cube du coup alors moi mon projet
c'est d'accompagner les salariés donc
d'être leur copilote financier pour
mieux comprendre leur rémunération et
les enjeux qui a derrière un bulletin de
salaire parce que la plupart des
salariés ne comprennent pas leur
bulletin et ce n'était pas lié à des
compétences ou un manque de
connaissances mais c'est vraiment qu'on
ne leur a jamais expliqué et l'idée de
check Tapei c'est d'apprendre aux
salariés à lire et comprendre leur
bulletins de salaire et aussi de leur
permettre d'avoir des experts
indépendants qui sont à leur service
pour leur permettre de comprendre leur
rémunération alors quelles sont les
attentes du ski cube du coup par rapport
au ski cube alors effectivement moi je
me suis lancée sur les réseaux sociaux
en avril 2021 aujourd'hui j'ai une
communauté d'un peu plus de 20000
abonnés tous réseaux sociaux confondus
donc des salariés qui sont désireux de
mieux comprendre leur paye mais je n'ai
pas la structure je suis pour l'instant
encore toute seule donc il va falloir
que je trouve mon business model que je
me lance que je crée une équipe et j'ai
besoin d'être accompagner là-dessus et
c'est sur ça que j'attends le ski cube
qui m'accompagne pour aller à un autre
niveau
cette idée de créer check tapis ça vient
d'où ça part d'un constat que les
Français en général ne savent pas bien
lire leur fiche de paye alors moi ça
fait 12 ans que je fais de la paye j'ai
été gestionnaire de paye ensuite j'ai
évolué vers des fonctions de chef de
projet SIRH et donc j'ai toujours
travaillé étroitement en contact avec
des salariés mais également avec des
gestionnaires de paie et des
responsables de paye et on c'est un
constat qui est unanime on ne comprend
pas le bulletin de salaire et c'est pas
un secret et à côté de ça
personnellement dans ma vie personnelle
un peu comme les médecins quand ils sont
un dîner de famille et on leur demande
tout le temps est-ce que j'ai un bobo là
est-ce que tu peux m'expliquer ben moi
quand je disais que j'étais gestionnaire
de paie il y avait toujours quelqu'un
qui me disait ah mais il y a un truc
bizarre sur ma paye j'ai pas compris ça
te dirait pas de regarder et parfois on
sait quand même qu'il y a un tabou en
termes de rémunération et parfois bah
même s'ils étaient pas très proches ils
avaient tellement pas de solutions
qu'ils étaient prêts montrer leur fiche
de paye leur sal pour que je puisse les
aider à mieux comprendre ce qui se
passait sur le rebutin c'est vraiment un
exemple c'est l'exemple même de
l'entrepreneuriat et c'est pareil pour
Vincent Miro il y a un problème qui se
pose il y a une demande clairement c'est
comme ça et puis l'entrepreneur va
répondre à cette demande et développer
une offre c'est le cas aussi de Vincent
Miro vous le constat que vous avez fait
c'est dans le milieu hospitalier c'est
ça exactement donc dans le milieu
hospitalier
remonter des équipes opérationnelles
soignantes médicales
qui qui ne trouvait pas qui ne trouvait
pas d'outils qui répondent à leurs
attentes des
attentes qui sont opérationnels et c'est
vrai que les blocs opératoires
aujourd'hui ont tous un logiciel qui
permet de de piloter leur activité mais
c'est des logiciels qui ont souvent une
vision un petit peu administrative et
c'est ça pose des soucis aujourd'hui
dans l'articulation des équipes à un
moment où on a besoin de beaucoup
d'agilité et on a besoin de partager
beaucoup d'informations pour faciliter
le travail des uns et des autres puisque
c'est c'est un endroit le bloc
opératoire qui qui fédère nombre
d'équipes qui travaillent en amont en
aval et au sein et au sein du bloc
opératoire voilà et donc notre objectif
c'est d'améliorer l'utilisation de ce
bloc opératoire pour utiliser au mieux
les ressources de l'hôpital mais c'est
aussi d'essayer de faciliter le travail
du personnel soignant et on sait qu'il y
a un enjeu sur le personnel soignant
personnel médical à l'hôpital c'est un
secret pour personne
dans le staffing de ces équipes là et
dans dans la qualité de vie au travail
de ces équipes à l'hôpital c'est une
dernière question parce que on bat des
records ces dernières années sur la
création d'entreprise en France l'année
dernière en 2022 il y a plus de 1
million de création d'entreprises qui
ont été faites durant l'année pourquoi
vous vous êtes lancé dans
l'entrepreneuriat qu'est-ce qui vous a
motivé c'est la liberté souvent on
entend cette petite ce petit refrain de
la liberté d'entreprendre parce qu'on a
plus de liberté quand on est
entrepreneur et pas salarié
alors oui ça c'est la liberté bien
évidemment en tout cas c'est vrai que
ces derniers temps on a de plus en plus
de facilité à entreprendre et c'est tant
mieux on est accompagné et d'ailleurs
avec le ski cube voilà on va être
accompagné aider donc c'est vrai que
c'est
l'entrepreneuriat c'est avant tout du
bon sens mais c'est aussi finalement
savoir
quand même prendre les bonnes directions
parce que voilà la liberté c'est 360 et
il faut faire les bons choix à des
moments où
le champ des possibles est total
et il faut choisir les bons acteurs avec
lequel faire faire les partenariats avec
lesquels monter monter les bons dossiers
pour pour avancer et voilà alors moi je
suis convaincue qu'en tant que salarié
on est aussi libre qu'en tant
qu'entrepreneur alors du coup c'est pour
ça que j'ai voulu me lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat parce que sur le
marché j'avais pas cette réponse pour
aider les salariés et maintenant je
pense qu'avec check à paye les salariés
auront le pouvoir d'être aussi libre que
les entrepreneur et de mener leur
carrière dans la direction qu'il
souhaite moi j'avais une dernière
question quand même Nicolas si vous
aviez devant vous une personne qui
hésite à se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat qu'est-ce que vous lui
diriez si elle a eu elle a son idée
depuis plusieurs années mais elle hésite
à se lancer à créer sa propre entreprise
qu'est-ce qu'elle conseille vous lui
donneriez
alors
faut pas hésiter en fait
faut pas avoir peur en fait c'est avant
tout ça mais quand on a une idée et
qu'on a envie c'est l'envie qui fait qui
fait l'essentiel dans l'entrepreneuriat
voilà
donc on a envie il faut y aller ensuite
on est accompagné non ça va lui dire
quand on a envie
c'est pas l'envie c'est pas n'est pas
n'est pas hors sol
on voit quelque chose on se sent pris
par une idée et il faut la développer
moi j'ai envie de dire que les
entrepreneurs sont des gens comme tout
le monde on n'est pas spécialement plus
visionnaire mais on fait la politique
des petits pas on met un pas devant
l'autre on regarde juste le pas devant
nous et si ça marche tant mieux et si ça
marche pas on Bifurk et donc ça se passe
très très bien juste pour conclure
Mathilde donc ce soir on avait Awa
Fofana donc les fondatrice de check tapé
et Vincent Miro le fondateur de Médoc
mais il y a trois autres start-up qui
vont intégrer le ski cube dans les
prochains jours il y a du new space avec
astrolab il y a yeldi c'est une fintech
et manuscrit qui est plutôt orienté vers
le marketing voilà bon on les découvrira
au courant de l'année on suivra vos
aventures aussi à tous les deux dans le
skyco voilà où on vous invite quand vous
voulez
merci à vous deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on va passer maintenant à
notre page cinéma
[Musique]
cette semaine c'est la réalisatrice gêna
sur rue qui vous propose son coup de
cœur regardez
[Musique]
le film que je recommande et le
long-métrage la piscine de Jacques doré
qui met en scène le couple mythique Romy
Schneider et Alain Delon ces deux
personnages se retrouvent sur une scène
très particulière autour d'une piscine
maintenant
[Musique]
dans la commune de Ramatuelle nous
sommes à la fin des années 60 et on se
rend très rapidement compte que ce petit
épisode de vacances va vite tourner
court et prendre un nouvel élan beaucoup
plus dramatique inspecteur l'évêque de
Marseille
[Musique]
à chaque accident c'est la même chose ce
que j'aime beaucoup dans la piscine
c'est avant tout le couple mythique Romy
Schneider et Alain Delon qui se
retrouvent artistiquement et aussi
finalement cette période très marquée
par mes 68 on le retrouve vraiment dans
le scénario avec des références à cette
génération qui a été très marquée par
l'émancipation de la femme et
l'émancipation même en général on est
juste après l'arrivée de la
contraception en France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dit qu'il en avait assez de Marianne
qui vous la céder et c'est bien sûr
aussi la lumière extraordinaire autour
de cette piscine dans il faut dire la
magnifique commune de Ramatuelle les
décors sont finalement très naturels et
parlent de même et c'est devenu ainsi la
piscine est devenue un véritable mythe
du cinéma français qui est très apprécié
à l'international et que et que j'aime
revisiter aussi régulièrement
[Musique]
et on poursuit cette page cinéma avec
vous Ludivine canard bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde alors quels sont les films à ne
pas manquer cette semaine alors il y a
Babylone de Damien Chazel qui était très
attendu le réalisateur de La la Land et
Wiz splash nous plongea Los Angeles dans
les années 1920 au cœur de la création
d'Hollywood un bouleversement de
l'industrie du cinéma qui va forcer les
acteurs et les actrices à se réinventer
une aire qui mêle ambition démesurée et
excès les plus fous le casting et deux
choix Brad Pitt Margot Robbie et la
révélation de ce film Diego Diego calva
voici un extrait
si tu pouvais aller n'importe où dans le
monde où est-ce que tu dirais je vais
faire partie de quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
j'adore cette réponse quelque chose qui
reste qui a vraiment du sens quelque
chose de plus important que la vie
c'est inscrit dans les étoiles je suis
une étoile
ce que je voudrais c'est que tout le
monde ça se fait
[Applaudissements]
on poursuit avec un autre film plus
grand public si vous avez aimé la guerre
des boutons ça devrait vous plaire oui
il s'agit de la guerre des Lulu de Yann
Samuel dans un orphelin Picard 4 amies
en séparables Lucas Luigi Lucien et
Luigi forment la bande des Lulu mais à
l'aube de la première guerre mondiale
l'établissement est bombardé oublié dans
le camp ennemi les orphelins sont livrés
à eux-mêmes ils vont devoir unir leurs
forces pour survivre en plein conflit
ces derniers devront aussi faire face à
l'arrivée d'un nouveau membre dans le
groupe on regarde un extrait faut qu'on
s'organise qu'on se voit aller ou dormir
ils annonçons partout dans le village
pour qu'on aille en Suisse la paga
là-bas moi c'est Moussa grand
pourfendeur des éléphants
[Musique]
alors un autre film qui parle d'une
bande d'amis est aussi à l'affiche
Ludivine oui Mathilde la comédie le clan
d'Eric fratécili raconte l'histoire de 4
braqueurs Corse Fred Achille max et
belette après avoir raté leur dernier
coup il décide de frapper fort en
kidnappant Sophie Marceau de passage sur
l'île de Beauté problème il la confondre
avec une parfaite inconnue et on termine
avec un film d'animation Ludivine oui le
secret des perlins du Brésilien aller à
Braou suit les aventures de Clyde et
brouhaux deux agents secrets de royaume
rivaux ceux du soleil et celui de la
lune lorsque les géants menacent
d'engloutir leur monde sous les eaux les
deux ennemis doivent s'allier et
dépasser leurs différences pour trouver
les Perlin et sauver la forêt je vous
propose de visionner un extrait
chez vous enfin dites-nous ce que vous
savez sur les berlines
[Musique]
et bien merci Ludivine canard est-ce que
vous avez une préférence parmi tous les
films que vous nous avez cité bah la
carte des Lulu comme ça je pourrais
rejoindre le groupe je suis plutôt
d'accord avec vous est-ce que vous aimez
les pommes oui et bien j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour vous à Villepreux il y a
un aboriculteur Antoine Frémin qui a
lancé les vergers de La Haye il propose
plusieurs variétés de pommes bio il les
produisent Julien Leroy vous propose de
découvrir cette ferme familiale donc
tout ce qui descend aura moins de sève
donc froid aura des fruits plus petits
indirectement donc tout ce qui redescend
hop pas de pitié on coupe bien que les
récoltes soient terminés Antoine freymin
ne chôme pas cet arboriculteur de 33 ans
a fondé les vergers de la haie en 2017 à
Villepreux sur sa parcelle de pommes
biologique de 4 hectares environ 50
tonnes de fruits ont été cueillies en
2022 dalinette Melrose ou encore opale
23 types de pommes cultivés sur ces
terres on a pris beaucoup de variétés
plutôt récentes qui maintenant ont les
critères de des maladies et qui sont
plus adaptées au bio avant on avait des
pommes qui flétrissaient qui devenaient
un peu farineuses ça passe plus du tout
maintenant consommateurs un ouvrier
agricole aide Antoine sur la partie
exploitation les pommes sont
conditionnées avant d'être proposé en
boutique ou expédié il prépare ce jour
plus d'une centaine de cagettes pour la
coopérative biodiles de France grâce à
cette calibreuse ça pèse le poids et
après ça tombe dans le dans le bac
au niveau du réglage que le responsable
a fait ici à la machine ces pommes de
variétés britburn peuvent être
conservées plusieurs mois dans cette
chambre froide d'une capacité de 80
tonnes grâce à un froid humide réglé à 2
degrés Celsius le fruit ne se dessèche
pas on récolte principalement pas locks
encore un petit peu en caisse
donc tout ça c'est en attente d'être
trier vendu et là de l'autre côté
on a toutes les caisses qui sont prêts à
être vendus qu'on doutait passer à la
calibreuse à l'origine nos
grands-parents étaient déjà dans
l'arboriculture ils étaient sur
Chambourcy mes parents se sont
développés sur Feucherolles d'Avron et
puis nous on reprend ici à Villepreux
cette boutique ouverte elle était 2022
au sein de la ferme attire une centaine
de clients par semaine les pommes mais
aussi les poires d'Antoine cultivées à
Feucherolles prennent place sur les
étales entreprises familiale oblige on y
retrouve les légumes bio cultivés aux
Mureaux par son frère la D98 c'est quand
même une route très passante donc les
gens regardent enfin sont curieux
viennent voir et puis évidemment vu que
c'est bon il reste on veut pas faire les
usines à pommes comme certaines
exploitations ou ils mettent de
l'engrais de l'eau et ça fait du navet
et nous c'est quand même le goût qui est
primordial sur la quantité depuis fin
2022 ces fruits sont proposés dans les
écoles et la maison de retraite de
Villepreux environ 7000 pommes sont
commandées chaque mois pour la
restauration collective de la commune
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant je tends un
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel devrait être dégagé
sur l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau
des températures couvrez-vous bien et
fera 0° à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et
Versailles et moins 1 degré à
Rambouillet mais les ressentis seront
d'environ moins 4 degrés dans
l'après-midi météo France prévoit
quelques rares averses dans le
nord-ouest du département à Versailles
et Rambouillet attendez-vous à de
l'appui avec un peu de neige au niveau
des températures il fera 3 à 4 degrés en
moyenne et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]